how are you doing today sir good how are
you i like your background or your
environment
i'm gonna say thank you um i was gonna
make a joke but i'm gonna jump right
into it okay okay
first i just want to start with how much
i enjoyed uh sac lunch bunch um so just
want to say thanks for that thank you it
was nice to hear um
one of the things i think that's great
about the disney plus mcu series is you
guys can tell these stories that could
never exist in a movie you know you get
to spend more time with each character
and you don't have to worry about it
taking up five minutes of screen time
yeah you sort of talk about the benefits
i guess like you know the ability to
tell these kinds of stories that are so
different
yeah i know exactly it's i mean you know
i think what's compelling about what
marvel or the approach they're taking is
and they were very clear early on it's
like this is very much part of the mcu
so it's it's the same you know they
should feel and look like the movies and
they can interconnect at any time so you
have that that level but but yes you you
get to to sit in a in a musical and and
you get to
um again spend time these characters and
and
also deliver i think a plot line that
that's that you know is not overwhelming
the story because it is again to me
hawkeye the appeal was the character
that was always the big appeal of the
show to me was was his humanity and
um and you know really just exploring
like who he is and the price of what
he's done and so
um you know i think being able to to
look at it that way and not have to
service some big overarching plot was
great
how long do you think before the musical
in the first episode is a real
production
um
i mean it will probably take us you know
it's probably a few couple you know a
year of workshopping and then
as soon as as soon as uh yeah as soon as
they say the word we're doing it um
yeah i don't know i hope it would be
great it'd be amazing if it did yeah
that that musical it's so good fans are
gonna like i was gonna curse fans are
gonna very much enjoy it
um i am curious though behind the scenes
what really surprised you about working
with marvel and making this series that
you're like completely didn't expect
i mean i think you know you you
obviously it's a it's a big world and a
and a big machine and you know and so i
think people sort of take that attitude
of like oh it's a it's a big machine and
you're stepping into it and um and that
it can be intimidating and overwhelming
but but
you know i think again the surprise was
how collaborative and and how um
how much support you get and and
yes it's a big world you're stepping
into and then yes that could be
overwhelming but they kind of really let
you focus in on you know your show and
and keep your head down and and sort of
you know do what's right what you feel
is right for the for the characters in
the story and like that's ultimately it
and and so the you know the bigger
intentions the bigger things of what's
going on around you they you know it's
kept at bay for you in some ways and and
um so yeah i mean again it was kind of
just the openness to to you know what we
were doing and and
and the philosophy of best idea wins i
mean that was i think you know it's it's
refreshing and also you know kevin feige
is
is the you know it's it's
it's his world and trend and so you have
a quite small sort of group of of of
brains as well that you're going to and
that have such a deep fan fandom for for
this world that's the thing they're
really passionate fans that's the number
one takeaway that you get as well it's
not it's not anything other than just
enjoying this world
i know you can't reveal too much but uh
what are you most excited for fans to
actually see in the series
uh most excited i mean you know again
it's the joy of these series is that
each episode i think has a different
layer that it adds in a different aspect
um but yeah again they're human
characters and and i you know we sort of
i
i came in and tried to sort of you know
keep that philosophy
throughout and the way we tell the story
and the way we approached the action you
know was to look at it again more from a
character point of view and so
um you know i think again
to me
it's marvel so it has all the scale you
want but but yes again a good action
sequence to me is more about you know
again if you can have two characters
bickering while you know
in a car chase it's it's more amusing
than than just you know big explosions
and what have you so so it's got that
texture to it and and that lightness
throughout which you know i don't think
you always get to do in these
yeah i already got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the first two
episodes can't wait to see the rest
thank you thank you very much thank you
you